supongamos que nuestro objetivo es
mostrar el mecanismo de esta reacción de
eliminación e1 y estamos pasando de este
alumno de alquilo en la izquierda a este
al que no lo primero que sucede es que
los grupos salientes se van y entonces
estos electrones de este enlace se
quedan con el cloruro formando una unión
cloruro y por cierto sabemos que los
aviones cloruros son unos muy buenos
grupos salientes pero en el proceso le
estamos quitando un enlace a este
carbono de acá así es que estamos
formando un kart vocación bueno vamos a
dibujar lo que nos queda este es el
esqueleto de nuestra molécula y aquí
estoy poniendo unos grupos metidos y el
carbono de rojo se encuentra por acá
este es nuestro carbó catión es un kart
vocación secundario y tiene una carga
formal positiva y es un kart vocación
secundario porque está enlazado
directamente a otros dos carbonos y si
lo vemos fijamente podemos darnos cuenta
de que hay posibilidad de reordenamiento
podemos tomar uno de los grupos met y
los del carbono rosa y
pasárselo al kart vocación y así lo que
tenemos es un desplazamiento del grupo
metilo y la razón por la que sucede este
desplazamiento del grupo metilo es
porque produce un kart vocación más
estable ahora tenemos únicamente un
grupo metilo en este carbono
y ahora tenemos un nuevo grupo metilo en
este carbono lo que hicimos fue mover un
grupo metilo del carbono rosa al carbono
rojo de acá pero en el proceso le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono que es
este carbono así es que ahora éste tiene
una carga formal positiva y es un kart
vocación terciario porque está enlazado
directamente con 3 carbonos está
enlazado con este con este y con éste
que ya dejó de ser un kart vocación ok
ahora el carbó cationes éste terciario
que sabemos que es más estable que un
kart vocación secundario pero además
también es estabilizado por el hecho de
que nuestro solvente es un solvente
polar pro tico así es que este es un
kart vocación muy estable en este
momento de la reacción pueden suceder
dos cosas por acá tenemos agua que puede
funcionar como un núcleo filo y si eso
sucede lo que vamos a obtener
él es el producto de una reacción de
sustitución pero nosotros lo que
queremos es ver el mecanismo de reacción
de eliminación porque aquí este producto
es de eliminación así es que en este
mecanismo de reacción esta molécula de
agua va a funcionar como una base y el
agua va a llegar y se va a llevar uno de
los protones de los carbonos
directamente enlazados con nuestro carbó
catión pero bueno en el caso particular
de esta reacción en la que obtenemos
como resultado este al que no pues
podemos ver que el al que no tiene un
doble enlace entre nuestro carbó catión
y el carbono de arriba a la derecha
entonces esta molécula de agua le tiene
que quitar un protón al carbono de
arriba a la derecha para que se forme
este al que no en particular la molécula
de agua le va a quitar un protón a este
carbono así es que vamos a dibujarlo
y por acá tenemos a nuestra molécula de
agua que va a funcionar como nuestra
base débil y el agua va a tomar este
protón un par de electrones libres de
este oxígeno llegan y se llevan a este
protón y entonces los electrones de este
enlace se mueven para acá para formar un
doble enlace y así es como obtenemos
este producto los electrones de este
enlace se mueven para acá y forman este
doble enlace y listo ya terminamos ya
mostramos el mecanismo de esta reacción
ahora veamos otra reacción de
eliminación en uno pero esta vez nuestro
objetivo es mostrar todos los productos
que podemos obtener con esta reacción
ahora que ya tenemos nuestro alcohol y
lo estamos haciendo reaccionar con ácido
sulfúrico y le estamos aplicando calor a
la reacción como ya hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores cuando tenemos una
reacción de eliminación con un alcohol
el primer paso es una transferencia de
protones el alcohol funciona como una
base y el ácido sulfúrico le dona un
protón así es que voy a poner un protón
por acá y lo primero que hacemos es
proponer nuestro alcohol entonces un par
de electrones libres del oxígeno llegan
y se llevan a este protón que provino
del ácido sulfúrico y entonces el
producto que nos queda es el siguiente
por aquí tenemos nuestra cadena de
carbonos y tenemos dos grupos metidos en
este carbono y el oxígeno por acá ahora
tiene 2
6 con hidrógenos todavía tiene un par de
electrones libres pero ahora tiene una
carga formal positiva así es que este
par de electrones libres que estoy
coloreando de rosa se llevan un protón
del ácido sulfúrico y forman este enlace
con él ahora la razón por la que sucede
esto es porque así se forma un grupo
saliente suficientemente estable es
mucho mejor que lo que sería un grupo
hidroxilo y entonces lo que sucede es
que los electrones de este enlace se
quedan en el oxígeno y esta molécula de
agua se va pero cuando sucede eso este
carbono de acá está perdiendo un enlace
así es que aquí en el carbono rojo es
donde se forma un kart vocación volvemos
a dibujar nuestro esqueleto de carbonos
el carbono color rojo es nuestro carbó
catión y es un kart vocación secundario
porque está enlazado directamente con
otros dos carbonos
es que tenemos aquí a un kart vocación
secundario y por supuesto tiene una
carga formal positiva y ahora ya que
llegamos a este punto nos ponemos a
pensar en los posibles reordenamientos y
nos preguntamos si hay algo que puede
suceder que forme un kart vocación más
estable al igual que en el ejemplo
pasado aquí puede suceder un
desplazamiento de un grupo metilo
podríamos tomar este grupo metilo y
desplazarlo a este carbono y entonces lo
que nos queda es esto aquí tenemos
nuestra cadena de carbonos acabamos de
pasar este grupo metilo a este carbono y
entonces aquí tenemos un grupo metilo y
en este carbono nos queda únicamente un
grupo metilo nuestro carbono de rojo
es este antes era un kart vocación pero
como desplazamos un grupo metilo a ese
carbono ahora ya no es un kart vocación
ya no tiene una carga formal positiva
ahora la carga formal positiva la tiene
este carbono de rosa porque acaba de
perder un enlace ok ahora este carbono
tiene una carga formal positiva y este
es un kart vocación terciario y sabemos
muy bien que carbó cationes terciarios
son mucho más estables que carbó
cationes secundarios pero bueno
regresando a la reacción como es una
reacción de eliminación e1 sabemos que
llega a una base débil y se lleva algún
protón pero en este caso hay varios
lugares de donde podemos tomar un protón
por ejemplo podría llegar una base y
llevarse un protón de este carbono
entonces dibujemos ese protón y llega a
la base y se lleva ese protón y en este
caso los electrones de este enlace
se mueven para acá eliminando la carga
positiva de este carbó catión y formando
un doble enlace
así es que dibujemos cómo queda ese al
que no por acá tenemos la cadena de
carbonos este carbono tiene un grupo
metilo y ahora tenemos un doble enlace
entre estos dos carbonos pero a ver
sigamos el trayecto de los electrones
los electrones de este enlace se
movieron para acá y ahora forman este
doble enlace pero espera un momento este
es sólo uno de los protones que se pudo
haber llevado la base débil qué pasa si
la base débil se lleva algún protón de
este otro carbono vamos a dibujarlo por
acá aquí tenemos nuestra cadena de
carbono con sus grupos metilo el carbono
rosa es
que tiene una carga formal positiva y el
carbono rojo es este pero entonces qué
pasa si llega a una base y se lleva uno
de los protones de este carbono pues
dibujemos el protón y la base llega y se
lleva ese protón y los electrones de
este enlace se pasarían para acá para
formar un doble enlace formando otro al
que no que vamos a dibujar ahora tenemos
nuestra cadena de carbonos tenemos los
dos grupos metidos y nuestro doble
enlace en este caso el doble enlace se
forma entre el carbono rosa y el rojo y
son los electrones de este enlace los
que ahora forman el enlace doble pero
hay un producto más que se forma en esta
reacción y para verlo tenemos que
regresarnos a nuestro carbó catión
secundario si no se reordena si no hay
un desplazamiento del grupo metilo
entonces puede llegar una base y
llevarse un protón de este carbono
también podría llevarse un protón
otro carbono adyacente a este carbón
pero este otro carbono no tiene protones
enlazados a él tiene puros grupos metilo
así es que la base no se puede llevar un
protón de este carbono pero si de éste
así es que dibujemos por aquí un protón
y entonces llega a una base débil y se
lleva este protón y los electrones de
este enlace se moverían para acá
formando un enlace doble y eso nos da
nuestro producto final que es un al que
no tenemos aquí nuestro esqueleto de
carbonos y el enlace doble se forma aquí
así es que estos electrones que estoy
dibujando de azul se movieron para acá
para formar este doble enlace en esta
reacción de eliminación e1 formamos tres
productos por lo que podemos ponernos a
pensar en cuál de éstos será el producto
mayoritario para resolver eso lo que
tenemos que hacer
nos a pensar en cuál es su grado de
sustitución entonces vamos a empezar por
este al que no tenemos aquí un doble
enlace entre estos dos carbonos y
tenemos 1 2 3 4 grupos al kilos
este es un al que no te tras sustituido
y por lo tanto debería de ser el
producto mayoritario porque es el al que
no más estable ahora vamos con este al
que no tenemos estos dos carbonos en el
enlace doble y esta vez tenemos
únicamente dos grupos al kilos entonces
es un al que no de sustituido y
finalmente este es un al que no mono
sustituido lo que tenemos aquí los dos
carbonos del doble enlace y tenemos
únicamente un grupo al kilo éste es un
al que no mono sustituido
este al que no proviene de la molécula
que tiene un kart vocación secundario en
el que no hubo desplazamiento de grupo
metilo por lo que éste no va a ser un
producto mayoritario de hecho sólo un
porcentaje muy pequeño de nuestros
productos van a ser monos sustituidos la
mayoría van a ser al que nos di y tetra
sustituidos y finalmente el al que no te
tras sustituido va a ser el producto
mayoritario porque es el más estable